hey everyone I'm Liana Galera coming to
you live from comic-con with one of my
favorite cats of all times please say
hello to the cast of Shadowhunters
anybody else that we're going to watch
we're gonna watch we look at it you set
yourself up it's pretty I really I
really I really you know we're actually
gonna go live right now on all you're
you guys you're at comic-con which is
the perfect place for you to be right
now it's just starting off are you ready
to see some shadow hunters walking
around and yeah no we good oh my god me
let's go because they're cosplaying all
the different characters on the show
it's amazing but you can see that should
be a thing people say pictures like look
at my cosplays I give nothing yeah
doesn't work these into the house isn't
one that is really excellent work time
when you guys are responding good I was
over the Latino have so much to talk
about
okay first of all this week's episode
directed by the one and only Paul Wes
yeah I couldn't imagine a better vampire
to take home of this show thank you I
agree no I dream what Paul did very good
very yeah I don't even know yeah he had
a very good vision and the cool thing is
coming from a world of like fantasy
we're not diving into our show wasn't
too different than we've got all the
rules was they were just before the time
and we were under wouldn't do that
okay well as you guys said this episode
had so much in it so much conflict and
it really set us up for the rest of the
season and give me your best teases for
what we can expect
well who's in charge of what who died
and you can tell the fans on this this
is an exclusive that you guys are
getting right here yeah we don't have
anything we can't tell you who dies but
we can't die oh yeah definitely we can
in who dies
Don you're really a many people right
now it's such a shame that you guys just
don't get along at all
and so I want to give you i holding
hands right I'm going to give you guys
an opportunity to call out your fellow
cast members Chad Andrus is all about
keeping secrets and we're gonna fill
some secrets right now giving Kiwi who
takes the longest to get ready
[Music]
own it we're done em taking one look
working away a new haircut so I mean
that was it was pretty fast
yeah that's always the heck I'd do if I
had enough that's why I was like less
because we have that nobody I'd rather
have her in the trailer
cuz she's the most polite the whole time
she's always it she's very sweet all
about she's the best person had that one
I even sought additional bonus oh this
is awesome at one all right on who can
you always find at the crafty table
hmm you the Matt Robert what are you
what are you packing on a bird okay I'll
help you stuff me Oh cookie stuff that's
very good for you no cookies always all
the fruits and vegetables I don't you
love watching your mom man please don't
say we go
gotcha conical yeah I'm not really
concerned about your mom we're concerned
about your dentist watching you need to
protect it we might interpret I'm
naturally enough though I don't get
cavities
that's good vampires compared against a
dental education on T my goodness happy
restriction who is most likely to burst
into giggles mid take I don't know
although we all do I don't know I keep
catching artery whatever you in a Castro
yeah Oh in the J bulla the really all ah
yeah if it wasn't a percentage of like
today happen the most selfies on selfies
of you don't you take away 12
yeah during this interview right we'll
take one all again I would say L 128
gigabytes of her phone I'm not just away
minute you have a new phone every day
yeah we need a super nice and fun more
fun what are you taking pictures of area
B angle lastly who would be the most
kick-ass to have by your side in a real
fight against edema
are you become kind of laminated we're
all walking in a physical way you gonna
fight all you got
I mean Nazis knock you out
what's one thing would never reach your
physicality hey calm down you'd be like
okay speaking that hug I think it's time
for a little romance checkup it's like
it's my job or something um give us a
little bit of what we can expect from
Clara's love life moving forward
thank you all right good I'm sorry love
in two seconds call me loving my limbs
no which will be tomorrow yeah rocky
sense would be record to be fair but I
think at this point Clary realizes that
she just needs to throw herself into
words ribbon and currently speaking you
know it's gonna Reverend against you i
yeah hey guys
it doesn't realize such as he does and
you thought about it very much smoking
it up in urbana yeah I see you man
that's good yeah you sure that beautiful
yeah kara back yup I mean I'm in it
yeah I was ordered yeah their facebook
status is this Colin
Emily it's also a little complicated
with Malik right now what can we control
coming up
having a blender and we put a hardening
you press fall fall fall fall fall
excuse me you mean because you're mixing
the heart you mix because it's one heart
after a while did you not insult thing
Malik right no I know I really know I I
think there's what the beauty you can
remake that part freeze it freeze it
yeah II thought what has it been like so
you guys to be a part of an on-screen
couple that has such a passion that fan
behind it oh yes amenable I mean the
you're so supportive and positive and
just the love of a you know kind of show
on on social media and after the show
layer so it's great yes tremendously
appreciate it good to go you know up in
one direction I hate to leave you and
then I'm going to workout with all I
hate us I think that we need to get some
easy some lemon yeah focus on yourself
yes she's doing her she's one of their
you have real love in your life
how do is doing right now how's it look
- it looks going good he's got find some
love don't worry I know you all are
wondering about that it's going to carry
mail
find another Gera we're great mark
little a second that's a good merit
dollar bank oh yeah iteration right
there or a little brand well you know
[Laughter]
I'm thinking of all the fans out there
who trying to transcribe what you're
saying for gifts right now we can we
show fad like anyone who has to edit
done I'm so excited because your real
life love the lovely Sarah Hyland it's
coming in from mysterious guest spot
what do you I know I say what can you
tease about her role I just you know
that we see that everyone fell in love
with that on set the cars the crew it
was a real joy to have on set she's been
with us since you know season one
obviously coming to visit me and having
a lot of debt as an actress with
phenomena
oh yeah no I'm sorry I shared how
special was it for you to be able to
have her in your work place it was one
point of what's nice about is when we
get to set it wasn't it wasn't so much
boyfriend-girlfriend it was two actors
working together and we got to separate
that and work with each other which is
really nice
very professional I can't say comparable
not allowed to mention any of those goes
up but yeah it was really good analysis
but one of those one of the things that
our et readers love so much about Sarah
is that she's not afraid to stand up to
all the social media bullies on there
she recently really stood up for herself
how proud were you of her incredibly
proud and like you know as the public
know Sarah's going through quite a bit
at the moment and for anyone to be
small-minded enough to trying enclose
her into a space that they just don't
understand I think is ridiculous
so I think the way she feels with it is
is incredible because you know people
need to understand more of your point of
view and at the same time be like you
know back off because you don't get it
you don't understand in a situation you
never will you can share an opinion but
when that opinion turns from love into
hate yeah
that's a negative and weird spewing
negativity into the world when really
all we need
I love that let's end this on an
amazingly positive note whoa guys give
me one word to describe your characters
journey and the rest of the season ready
Dom do you want kick us off
what's up for j-pop right cat brutality
filling it Oh who's gonna spill some bit
I'll read up competition whoo what's
next for Izzie and Alex Wow frustration
yeah exactly
thank you guys so much for stopping and
I really should have the best comic-con
say bye to your fans ah
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
you